[Music]
our next speakers will in fact talk
about a specific relationship between
men's at Manos between art and
engineering in the world of architecture
we are very honored today to have with
us architect IM Pei class of 1940
formerly with the firm of Pei Cobb Freed
and partners of course mr. pay is very
well known for many many buildings and I
will not list them all some of them are
particularly important for the arts
including of course the Louvre the East
Wing of the National Gallery in
Washington DC and many MIT alums are
familiar particularly with the Morrison
Hall for the Dallas Symphony Orchestra a
remarkable building at MIT mr. Pei has
not only designed the weasoner building
on AIM Street but the arch to that
building which is a gateway into East
Campus as you cross Ames Street also not
I think coincidentally when you are
walking toward the campus frame his
three buildings in the main quadrangle
with in perspective the MIT dome over
all the three buildings on the main
campus with their very stark geometry of
verticals and horizontals triangles and
rectangles most recently or not most
recently but among mr. paise most recent
works are the Bank of China in Hong Kong
and the Four Seasons Hotel in New York
City and I think we will be hearing
about some of these works today
mr. Pei has also been affiliated with
MIT since 1972 as a member of the
Council for the Arts at MIT and we
appreciate his years of membership on
that group
talking to mr. pay today will be Dean
William Mitchell Dean Mitchell has been
at MIT since 1992 and he is particularly
well known for his book published by the
MIT press the reconfigured AI which
deals with digital photography and in
fact visual images that do not represent
the real world Dean Mitchell is working
very hard in the School of Architecture
to lead the School of Architecture into
the 21st century with his virtual design
studios and the Design Studios of the
future using computer technology to
create a seamless process from the
initial designs through to the
communications with clients engineers
and others please help me to welcome
I am Pei and Dean William Mitchell
[Applause]
redoing the loo is blistered sounds much
better redoing the Louvre is an
extraordinarily large and complex
project involving technical problems
organizational problems political
problems certainly problems of very
complex cultural symbolism so what we
thought we'd do today is to ask mr. pay
to describe a little bit of his thought
processes what the problem is about the
solution that he finally derived and
then we'll take some time to discuss
this was truly magnificent project first
mr. pinky
professor Morrison talked about hundreds
of centuries I'm talking today on the
subject of the Louvre about eight
centuries history of 800 years but these
are very important 800 years for the
French at least
[Laughter]
it's a building of the period during
which French nation was born it's a
period that I would say this roughly
parallel the recent French history in
fact it's also a wonderful symbol for
their math lease of French civilization
so therefore the problem of the Louvre
for the architect it's not just a
technical problem architectural problem
but it's a it's a problem that has many
many challenges I would like to start
off by telling you something about the
history of the Louvre now I don't have
too much time but I tried to make it
very brief and therefore incomplete
it started in 1202
by I think you can call him a French
King Philip August who built this
fortress on the right side of the Seine
to protect the Ile de France which is
now they do dacite which is the place
where the French the heart of French
life at that time in Paris took place it
was billed as a fortress a lot Don John
is they call it and it's important
because I I wish I'd taken some slides
to show you what it was but it is like
today but anyway it was a fund it was a
wonderful building where they put
prisoners with a good ammunition it's a
very important place to protect let's
say something that they consider to be
very important it lasted as a launcher
as a fortress for roughly as I would say
maybe 200 years it did not become really
a place for the Kings living until about
the end of 14th century and I think
Charles the fifth was the king that one
should remember because that's the
beginning of luth not only as a place
for the King to live in but also the
beginning of French art the first
library of France was there and a
collection of many many objects of
Charles the fifth was this display there
now for how many years since then 1402
today I would say 500 years 600 years
nearly all the French kings so you know
of any importance everybody lived there
died there Meryton and amp upon them so
therefore it's a it's an important place
so therefore this is not really
surprising that when someone like myself
I guess I can consider myself an
American of Chinese descent I ask the
temple was a very important part of
French history so I'm gonna go through
this in two phases to show you what I
went through phase one lasted five years
from 1983 to 96 years to 1989 and during
those six years the the plan was laid
how to deal with the problem that's a
very complex problem and the pyramid was
built but before the pyramid was built
we had a lot of trouble we wasted two
years it's a media that I had to deal
with at that time and I was totally
unprepared and my French language is
just not adequate for that purpose but I
had to deal with the media to try to
convince the French that this was the
right thing to do so therefore even
though it took 60
but only four of those six years with
the vertical architecture and the
building of the phase one now phase two
is less spectacular in a sense of public
information but it's perhaps the more
important of the tool because it
completed a wing called Richelieu and
without that wing there will be no
Louvre today and we couldn't get that
wing until 1985 the wing I tell you what
the wing is the wing was occupied by the
Ministry of Finance
everything's were saying Napoleon the
third only two hundred years hundred
fifty years no left eighteen fifty six
hundred and fifty years and they refused
to move
[Laughter]
and at that time the pyramid is already
discussed and people say okay if you
must have it this meter all must want it
okay
but I said look here there's no point to
build a pyramid if we don't have the
Ministry of Finance so that gave the
president another headache but long
story short we moved them out in 1989 so
the second phase is the building of the
Richelieu wing it's architectural II not
at all spectacular but very important
because why because I had to keep the
facade the only thing I could do is
inside and we've demolished everything
inside except big Swede up Second Empire
rooms very he must go to seal and two or
three staircases and the rest originally
was completely gutted so as a major
engineering project but not very
spectacular except there's some
interesting things inside which you will
see when you come so because of time I'm
gonna start with face one quickly excuse
me we have the technology here oh oh I
see oh I see now anything
okay now Louvre as you know it perhaps
without too much debate among architects
and planners it's perhaps the most
important urban composition in the world
today there's no other that can compare
with it
its history 800 years in the building it
started as a fortress and then was added
on by Kings after Kings
but the important things to remember the
build the roof
probably I would say Charles to fear
Francis the first Henry the second Henry
the fourth louis xiii louis xiv and
eventually napoleon the first and the
pauline the third and there are many
other kings in between there added it's
something to it but those were the
important kings and it can also be said
that perhaps every important french
architect nearly every from let's go to
Monsod to Laveau and the louis xiv many
many others an adventure love well
Visconti they all participated in the
building of it so therefore it's not
surprising that if you come into this
wonderful complex which already formed
and you try to do something with it now
the reasons why something had to be done
to the Louvre is for the reason that you
know that it was built first as a
fortress and it was added on and added
on to try to make it more comfortable
for King after King and to turn into
Museum in 1793 the convention it's a
move that was correct interesting
because it became Luke became a public
museum for the first time two hundred
years ago but it was not at all suitable
for a museum because it was meant for
for life for people who were Kings to
live in so Louvre has never really
worked as a museum I was there for the
first time on a fellowship not MIT but
Harvard fellowship I did me see it might
be fellowship but it was during the war
I couldn't do anything with it
I live across the street from the Louvre
and a very tiny lower hotel and I went
over there every day to look at it and I
tell you in those years you really have
to have time to see the Louvre because
you get lost in it and you don't know
where anything was no toilets no
restaurants nothing of that sort
but it has one had a wonderful
collection and you have to go back time
and time again to find surprises and
that was the way Louvre was to all of
you to many others until something
happened in 1989
so therefore Louvre it's a wonderful
complex of buildings the Louvre Museum
was not Louvre Museum happened to be a
tenant in the Louvre that's all it was
occupied by the Ministry of Culture
running the Museum of fans it was
occupied by by the Ministry of Finance
occupied by many others Louvre Museum
occupy a long long wing along the sand
and it's about I would say 800 meters
long and that wing was and almost
impossible to go from one end to the
other without going up and down and and
and there so therefore most people who
went to the Louvre is I did probably
only saw maybe 25% of it look the rest
you just missed you have to have a guide
and I didn't have a guy so therefore I
had to go back time and time again to
find new things new surprises so Louvre
did not work as a museum and the French
knew it but they wanted finally and the
material to do something about it and
the one move there was the perhaps the
most important movable
I mentioned earlier it was the
recapturing of Richelieu wing from the
Ministry of Finance
now this is perhaps not a very good
slide I apologize but you can see the
importance of Lu in the heart of Paris
because it's situated perhaps and the
most important really in center harbor
of Paris and yet it's separated the left
bank from the right back there's no way
to penetrate except by car from left
bank which is below to the - to the
right back
so it became actually a barrier and that
became an urban design problem
our first magnitude because we have to
open up the loop the open up the loop
then you rejoin the two parts of Paris
not by car you can always drive around
but by on foot and this is one of the
challenges that is least talked about
perhaps in my opinion the most
importantly the axis of the Louvre leads
all the way to Sacramento and it all
probably is again when I say the most
important urban composition I really
should say that it's the most important
axis up - well there's no axis like that
that leads all the way from the Louvre
to such a man it went through the garden
of the Louvre which although plus de la
Concorde up strands Alizee to the Arc de
Triomphe and then on to Lodi false and
then let it want to be on now the Louvre
this is a diagram of the Louvre to show
you the gray area part was occupied by
the Ministry of Finance
the ochre the yellowish color wing 800
meters long half a mile long occupied
not just by the museum by the museum and
by the museum administration of France
and French bureaucracy I tell you takes
up a lot of space so it's not all busy
you can see that people come by the one
side of the courtyard and enter there
while you're waiting in line you're
lucky good day you don't mind but then
you be pestered by people trying to sell
you all kinds of things that you don't
want but but nonetheless they're people
three million people continue to come
why first collection but you really have
to go through a really a very
uncomfortable experience in the process
now what I saw at that time when I was
asked by the French government to say
can you do something about the museum I
don't know but anyway I'll try and the
one thing that became apparent to me
when I look at this problem I said the
Ministry of Finance has the goal
and I see the reason is simple as a bee
when you want to build a mountain museum
what loo is why it is not about the
museum for simple reason and that is in
more than modern Museum which I knew
well there and because I just finished
the National Gallery already so about
50% of exhibit space has to be matched
by 50% of supporting spaces reserved
conservation laboratories restaurants
auditorium lecture halls public's
reception spaces toilets things like
that but you did have tiny little toilet
in fact I remember very well that when I
went there I frequently have to leave
the loop because I could find a place to
go and remember when you leave the
Louvre some people don't come back again
you know so they lost a lot of people
it's not really surprising that the
average stay of visitors to the Louvre
is only one hour and a half
whereas National Gallery's three and
half hours Metropolitan Museum dancing
so I said that the key to the making loo
function as a museum is to change the
loo from 800 metre long up and down up
and down to something very compact but
you can give up this way the floor where
the Spanish paintings were or still are
and give it to other uses but you must
move the Louvre to that part in that way
you accomplish two things which is
essential to making Louvre Museum
function number one you can excavate
that Court which is in gray area the
Napoleon court we can go down two levels
it goes to the level of the send which
is about 10 meters down you can go down
two levels and you can recapture half a
billion square feet of space just by
excavating that and why not you can use
that space for reserve you can use that
space for all the infrastructure support
that a modern museum needs because under
the old loop there's no foundation
there's no space there's some pipes and
that's about all but nothing there
there's some sewers it goes through but
but that is the key to the to making the
Louvre into the modern museum second
reason is that if you put the center of
the loo not on one side down below but
really in the middle of that grey area
you've got the center of gravity of the
Louvre right there and from that point
you can go to the three wings Luther
three wings there norm venus de milo is
there and Mona Lisa is there and to the
Richelieu and - sulie very short
distance not 800 meters anymore it's
going to be only about something as 50
meters the difference so that you can
divide loop into really three parts even
though the Inc interconnected upstairs
three parts and each part is at least
a several days visit so a big Museum you
may wonder whether you need a museum
this size but be that as it may it's a
big museum and that's the only way to
solve the problem so therefore I told
the president I say you've got to do two
things you've got to let us dig under
the court because there may be relics
there the project could have been
stopped if they found something
important there and then you also have
to find a way to move the Ministry of
Finance
I at this point it's not so funny at
that time because
but this tells you something about the
the man who is still the president in
the France I don't know of any heads of
state in the world that has the kind of
depth of understanding of the history
and culture not only a France but of the
world it's really a remarkable man he
may not be the greatest politician I
don't know time with hell but he was and
he is an exceptional leader when it
comes to art and culture and I could not
have done anything there without him
that's obvious the court before we did
anything with it was a parking lot it's
a parking lot for the bureaucrats that
occupied the Ministry of Finance
the court after excavation finding one
year archeologists were thinking were
really literally with brushes and they
found things all right but nothing
terribly important because this court
unlike the court which I wish I had
slides to show you where the marvelous
tomjohn foundation is now on display
which when you go there you see this
court was inhabited by people who served
the Kings Baker's their cobblers there
there's a little church and that's what
all and therefore there's nothing that
is so important that they say stop we
were very fortunate from 84 to 85 that
year we were on waiting to see what
happened we wish they discovered nothing
the archaeal archaeologists because wish
they found something but anyway they
found nothing of importance and we
proceeded to to get the green light now
here I want to show you the organization
of the loop this is the court the rest
of the loop is not shown here is only
then the podium court by putting some an
object something in the center of this
court let's say in Napoleon call you can
connect the three pavilions in a very
short and direct way and very
understandable you can see it when you
are in the court or in the hall below
you can look out and you can see the
norm Richelieu and suley and that
clarity of orientation is key to a big
Museum
this is a an urban studies to try to
ventilate Paris you must first ventilate
the roof to ventilate the Louvre you
have to do several things yo can come
over from the left bank over Palm Desert
which is a pedestrian bridge the
wonderful bridge architectural II from
engineering point of view wonderful
bridge and then you enter into cookery
and then turn left but you have to do
two things in order to make it truly
open one is that you have to open that
passage under Italy capacity ratio to
lead you to the plastic Palais Royale
which is right and then from then on to
pal area and then to Pompidou Center
which you know second thing that you
must also do is to open up the garden a
new bridge is being built I think it's
about to start construction here so that
you can walk from or say which is where
the wonderful impressionist collection
is today from or say all the way to
Duluth and that will open up the loop
then once that loop is open up in no
longer as a barrier it becomes a
connector this was a drawing done by
Steve who's here steve-o's I showed this
drawing to the President and he was not
shocked perhaps he was the only man
there was not shocked when I showed it
to the press they were shocked and I'll
tell you from that point on as I say 18
months of just nothing but harassment by
the media but still we got the green
light and
the president as well as his official
who was in charge of the Louvre was
important and Piazza he said let's dig
because that the archaeologist has
already said it's okay let's take and
this was what you see and that was the
beginning of another furor and people
demonstrating and everything except
trying to they did they didn't do
anything really serious like committing
suicide like that but but very close
very close there were few now I'm good
to go quickly because of time quickly to
show you how the building process did
and the building of this palace is
remarkably fast the French contractors I
incredibly good I have to they're very
good these are slide shows the
construction the whole hold this in the
podium hall caught by the way this is
not the rest it's the only one the
important part this is the part where
the pyramid must be merge and the square
grid that you see the structural steel
member there they're all on bearings
they can move and they're supported on
four columns and that's all
we had about sixty or some size because
they have from one vantage point they
took pictures every so many months and
but I want to show you a few so that's
very quick but it took it took 18 months
to reach this stage and at this point I
would say it's the end of phase one it
was open in spring 1989 and meteor on
was there to cut the ribbon and it was
rather well received by then but still I
would say there are there were maybe 30
or 40 percent people still not very
happy with it and for any number of
reasons and but nevertheless it was
built and since this is MIT is all I
have to bring this time if I show to
other other audience they would not be
interested in it and I'm going to show
you some of these slides of the
construction but one thing should also
interest you that the French government
made no secret of it they want
everything to be made in France and the
only exception which I asked the
president to allow us is to have the the
all the tension elements made in
Massachusetts
by a small rigging company that did the
the the America's Cup yacht the yachts I
don't know what a Bill Koch is here not
for the years my hahaha we are we are
the best and I show him some samples of
the rigging how the turnbuckle was fit
into the cable and all that and he was
fascinated with it and because you liked
it so much that he didn't even bother to
say yeah is there French equivalent to
it we'll just say go ahead we did it on
the other hand I'm as a passing the
glass problem you see glass has to be
white has to be clear if the glass is
not clear
this is laminated you know it's double
layer it's very sick it's about almost
3/4 of an inch thick it's not clear be
green and if you see it through the
corner of this it will be very dark
green bottle green so therefore that is
not a very acceptable because the Louvre
you see the composition of the loop must
be seen and the ochre color stone
shouldn't look green so therefore I
requested the French manufacturer
sangban to make this glass
they say no we no longer make them and
then finally they say well if you build
one thousand pyramids we'll make them
for you
so I didn't report this to the president
I went to a German firm shop class I say
can you make it yes we can
Sango Bassett will make it
I'm going to go very quickly the making
of the period the pyramid has one virtue
it's a very stable form you know that
and consequently it requires the least
amount of steel in order to support it
and consequently if you use finest
technology available to you
technologically to build it it will be
the most transparent perform and it must
be the most transparent because you you
want to see that composition that
composition is so important to the world
not just to write so you may ask do you
need something that projects many
architects in France as well as abroad
suggested why not just have have a glass
sheet on the ground you know and and you
bring light in just as well but I said
no I said you have to have you have that
space you go into this the lower level
ten meters down nine meters down and you
don't want to have a glass ceiling that
would they may mean something to some
ceiling you want space and so something
has to project and I defended a pyramid
and the pyramid for those of you who
know France it's a very important symbol
to French I think the fans are probably
more conscious of pyramid as a form than
any other people because of Napoleon I
guess they really went to Egypt they
took a lot of things away from Egypt
so the pyramid form is necessary to give
you space so when you give you light
give you space but at the same time
transparent you can see through it and
also you need a simple because if this
is going to be the main entrance to the
loop it cannot be just subway entrance
system cannot be
glass was put in this manner and for a
long time there was a debate can you
clean the glass and they will try
different ways we they hired some
Indians from Canada to clean it they
they even try robot eventually we clean
by a little bit but finally they we got
some out alpinist to kill up there
hang the rope from the tip of the
pyramid and wash it and only took two
days to wash it but now it took less now
one day is all we need
so the washing problem no longer problem
but for while that became also a problem
because the French won't find any reason
to object to it and cleaning the pyramid
also kept us quite involved now now
you're inside the space and and you can
see the loop we can see the loop through
it
ah that was didi but no booing no boo
lots of applause I was
ah I like the photograph you don't see
anything
there's the story about this statue in
during louis xiv time short of time i I
would try to go quickly the louis xiv
time they invited and it shows that in
those years the kings of france are
already very cultured people they he
invited Bernini from Rome to come
Benigni just finished the st. Peter's
arcade and you know that that's wing
that enclosed that space perhaps then
dong-hee Umberto Meany were the two most
important architects at that time and
the French King wanted the best so he
wanted ride it when they need to come to
do something in the back of the loop not
the first part in the back of the loop
and and he was there six months and he
did not survive the French architects
and the only thing he left behind a few
things he left behind and not only of
importance but the only big thing that
he left behind is the statue of louis
xiv but that was made in rome that and
it was shipped to France afterwards and
believed what he never liked it because
it was his image at that time was 25
years ago he was a young man then he's
no longer young so so he banished it to
to a Versailles and then remained there
and because it was not known it was
never vandalized and never broke never I
mean never been there it was never
destroyed during the war because they
just left there so but it would be those
marbles vandalized by a man from
Brittany and that kiss I guess and no
longer salvageable but I persuaded the
conservator of Versailles to let us make
a cast of it the only way and they did
and it's made in lead and I thought you
should put it there to remember him as
someone who tried
[Laughter]
but that very important that location is
I needed something there to terminate
the axis of trans Eliseo something that
that axis of low note the low note axis
was not terminated and looked because
the loop is looping like this like this
so it has to be terminate not by the
pyramid by something else has something
strong and I was fearful of
commissioning a French sculptor at that
time you don't know what's going to
happen I'm perfectly frank about it I
just don't know what so that was my
escape from a responsibility now second
phase of the loop not spectacular
not at all Emily Michael but extremely
important because now it opened only a
few months ago if you go there now you
understand why the pyramid was put there
in the first place
and I think the vindication of the whole
plan is now made possible through the
completion of this wing and for that
reason even though architectural II it's
not spectacular because the facade had
to be kept and everything has to be
internalized done inside number two I
had to work with two French architects
which is reasonable because after all
you know can't hog it off now you see
the under the Napoleon Court and this is
what it looks like this is ten meters
below ground you go up three sets of
escalators to an intermediate level
still below ground and you can enter
into the three wings of the Louvre and
the fourth wing going this way goes to
shops parking bus terminal eventually
all the buses that you see on Rue de
Rivoli as well as on the K would
disappear
they have now they are underground now
so urbanistic li that's another very
important contribution and below at this
low level we have auditorium where
restaurants we have a reception area for
the young people and we have a bookstore
enormous bookstore and sharps and and
meeting rooms and Conference Center
everything is there but below this level
is all circulation there's a truck way
to connect all the departments
underground and there's a large reserve
so that all the collection nearly all
the collection loop now comes back home
now we have to talk briefly about
Richelieu wing
even though architectural II as I say
it's not very spectacular the two o
courts were proposed way back to be
covered
they were parking and trucking for the
Ministry of Finance before so not use by
covering it we can turn it into an
exhibition space for French sculpture
and and further we also proposed to dig
down below the Richelieu wing as you see
it so that the two courts are connected
at the lower level and this is this was
this was a truck trucking area which now
become exhibition area for French
sculpture
this wing house for departments the
sculpture Department the oriental
antiquities Department the absurd art
which is probably the most important
absurd art collection in the world and
paintings
I put this in in mostly again because
this is MIT this is a pyramid about 50
feet square inverted why invert it
because it's its position at the place
where the circular rotary is and you
don't want to see any projection they're
coming up because one pyramid is quite
enough but to use the same team and we
want to bring light in this is the
intersection if you go to the bus
terminal to the parking and to the shops
you have to go through this point so
therefore it's nice to have something to
to make people feel they're still in the
loop so now this suspended pyramid is a
major engineering project it was
designed by a man Peter Rice of Arab
associates in London and too bad I don't
have the Torrens is actually a very
brilliant design the whole thing is
there are only four rods in the center
or suspended and the rest are all cables
is cables and four rods and that's all
and it has one other very exciting
by-product clearly I was very proud of
it the another very important byproduct
of this is the prismatic effect of the
glass you see that glass because we
don't have to keep water arraign I love
this because inside we can polish the
edges of the glass and bevel it by
beveling at the spectrum of the colors
came out so at times you see when the
day sunny day like this it's just a
rainbow inside it's really quite
spectacular we go there make sure you go
there good sunny day
now the not the Richelieu wing one thing
has to be done to the Richelieu wing
because it's about the painting
collection is perhaps the most important
French painting collection and not
perhaps definitely and yet people don't
go there because the the French
conservatives wanted upstairs because
the daylight and they are very very
[Music]
insistent on using daylight our
conservators are less so very insistent
and for that reason they take the attic
space they have seen not very high but
to get up there you have to walk up 75
feet vertical space and most people
don't walk up there
so they miss a lot of visitors I was
totally about maybe at the most 10 or 15
percent of people go up to that floor
and that's a great pity so I proposed to
put in escalators I hate to do that it's
a 19th century building and you don't
intrude in install something like that
unless you have a good reason that was a
big battle but there was one and and
today nobody disagreed that it's
absolutely needed because otherwise the
interconnection up in 30 please it's
very very difficult
object that I'm gonna show you the
sculpture already actually object that
these are the Maximilian tapestries
never shown before no place to show now
they have a place and it's a mess the
Maximilian tapestries that must receive
they're very dimly lit because of the
color of the threads now before I go
into this this work here was done by
architect the amount of France of Paris
France and my role in the sculpture
garden and this is what they call really
among that hair so like a coordinator I
participated in all the decision-making
I chose them as my
architects I had that responsibility but
they should get the credit for it now
this was oh lewb the lighting our
paintings is a it's a really very
special science really is and it's
extremely important it's never studied
enough but just hasn't been we don't
have a good day like galleries in in
America we don't have in the National
Gallery you don't have it in Museum of
Fine Arts in Boston they're all like
this
there are lay lights with skylight on
top and even though it could have been
artificially lit and you wouldn't know
the difference and another disadvantage
that this the skylight is very bright
and therefore the brightest is the
ceiling the second brightest is the
floor the walls where you want the light
to be looks dark and consequently we
decided this is something we want to do
a piece of research on and I think one
of the major breakthrough I consider in
this wing is in the lighting the
lighting solution is this we make the
ceiling added into three layers the
first layer is cross skylight with a UV
filter of course and then below the
glass is an egg crate an egg crate is
carefully calculated so that the
orientation is such so note the rec
sunrays will go come in it will have
been better if they were movable because
then we get good light all year round
all seasons unfortunately the French
have experience with conservator our
maintenance crew they say it won't work
here
and they're there right there right
there right so we use fixed louvers that
don't have to be touched we cut off a
lot of light a lot more light than we
want it to but it does remove the
headaches of the Guardian and those
doing their job and the reason of the
big cross is that people have to walk
there so it has to be wide enough for
people to walk to clean to real and and
that sort of thing but you can see the
sky if you are walking on one side but
but the light is you see now is dialect
deflected to the walls it's no longer
coming down to the floor so the walls
now up the right and they get light and
that is turn out to be something that
the French conservators are very
conservative and they accepted this and
they now claim this is the best in the
world it happens
something has to always be stay like and
this is a very important suite of
paintings by Rubens celebrating Marie
the Medicis journey and eventually to
apotheosis all the way and you can see
again the light is no longer bright and
the ceiling it's directed to the wall
and and this is another version of it
depending this is an octagonal room
that's a long room and the previous one
I think it's a square room and this is
the way the light looks no reflection no
reflection I guarantee that no
refractory and
all right Richelieu wing was finished in
November open in November 9 1993 exactly
200 years after the founding of the loop
and richly winged together with the
Napoleon Court is now complete and
therefore loop finally functions that's
the way we had planned to and I some of
these slides are mostly to show you what
it looks like when it's all finished and
ladies young lady is celebrating the
event so there you are
I I think that's uh I used up too much
time sorry
you